Hong Kong's leader says that he wants to
tighten National Security legislation as
soon as possible to include offenses
such as treason Insurrection and
Espionage John Lee says the city cannot
afford to wait any longer to build on
beijing's National Security Law that was
enacted after a widespread Crackdown on
mass
protests bat
mouthing
political attacks will continue that is
exactly why I want the
government to be up
and in full gear to explain what we are
doing here loud and clear
confidently and rightly tell the world
we are just protecting ourselves from
your
attacks Patrick ful has more from Hong
Kong well it's going to make some
difference certainly and the government
isn't wasting any time to set this in
motion the legislature is going to be
gathering to kick off this consultation
process and John Lee has pledged
previously to enact article 23 by the
end of this year he reiterated that it
needed to be done as soon as possible
because the existing legislation that is
in place namely the Beijing imposed
National Security Law he said was like a
car with parts missing article 23 will
notably include laws against sedition
Espionage and will also ban foreign
political organizations from conducting
any sort of political activity here
there was some concern expressed about
the length of the consultation period
which will last until at the end of
February that means there's only one
month compared to the three months
people were given in 2002 when the
government first tried to roll out
article 23 before it was ultimately
sheld remember article 23 is part of
Hong Kong's mini Constitution which has
been in place since the Handover in 1997
it is required to enact this legislation
and John Lee said that it's been waiting
for 26 years to do so
today now Andrew L is an independent
China strategist and he is with us from
Hong Kong sir let's get to the heart of
the matter pro-democracy activists in
Hong Kong will see this as a further
tightening of Beijing control beijing's
control of Hong Kong agree or
disagree well this is total
misunderstanding uh what one country to
systems is all about because don't
forget um the formula begins with one
country and then the Hong Kong's
Constitution uh includes the article 23
provision right from the very start 26
years ago but then when an attempt was
um um was made to introduce it in 2003
um because for lack of sufficient
explanation for for lack of a sufficient
um atmosphere in the society um the
attempt had to be abandoned and it's now
over
20 23 more years um and then a lot of
loopholes uh remain to be plucked and
Beijing has learned a bitter lesson as a
result of the umbrella movement and then
more recently uh the black kind of riots
uh threatening not only Law and Order in
Hong Kong but also uh beijing's
sovereignty over Hong Kong because part
of the protest demanded Independence for
Hong Kong and then um lots of indication
suggest that there are um the foreign
forces were aiding and abetting all
these protests so Bing learned a bit
lesson Hong Kong learned a bit lesson
and now is the time to to pluck the
loopholes what would Hong Kong's leader
uh be able to do with these proposed
laws that he currently cannot
do well um because um many countries
many territories have National Security
legislation uh including the United
States the All European countries um but
then of course the Safeguard in Hong
Kong is Hong Kong's robust Judiciary
because um our rule of law uh has got a
very high International reputation
sitting on our courts our foreign judges
in even the um um the high the high
courts and and Court of final appeal um
as in the case of the current case of
the trial of Jimmy Li um the process has
been um extremely robust and open
because I mean it's open trial so so
there are safeguards but of course the
enactment of the National Security Law
is not peculiar to Hong Kong as I said I
mean it's
everywhere well so the the uh the
legislation as it currently stands uh
creat creates a new sabotage offense of
unlawfully using a computer or
electronic system to endanger National
Security unlawfully using a computer or
electronic system you see it's things
like that that will uh fuel the argument
of pro-democracy activists that this is
not just about National Security it's
about political
control well the the so-call pro
democracy activists uh in fact that you
look at the demands uh part of the
demand called is a greater universal
suffrage But the irony was that um
universal suffrage one man one vote was
offer to them but it was rejected
because um the one the the one man one
more over had to comply with the Hong
Kong mini Constitution which is that the
candidate had to be prescreen and then
the offer uh was initiated by Beijing um
uh on beijing's initiative is never
never included in the joint um
declaration with Britain handing over
Hong Kong it wasn't there it was
beijing's initiative to offer one man
one world but it was rejected um even
though the conditions were um were in
compliance with the um Hong Kong's mini
Constitution so there was a lot of
misunderstanding there but be that as it
may um these are gring loot post treason
uh Insurrection um sabotage and
Espionage well these are the kind of
offenses which are included in many
National Security laws around the
world Andrew lond thank you very much
for joining us in the program this
hour